fast to have serious
catching between regarding retirement
and just be straight up honest.
No fluff. Do a retirement planning
without having a family. Say, "What? How
does this work?" Okay.
Oh, yeah. You're right, Jack.
It's not just ABW, but all Western
women, but in particular ABW, when they
get attitude, I'm like,
what? I just keep on going.
See my honey.
Yeah,
she's better than you.
No, they don't. We don't owe them [ __ ]
We owe them what they've given us.
Nothing.
All right.
Okay guys, so we're doing the
walkthrough again with this lambda. Um,
who wants to open up start this?
Try to go through it again. Anybody want
to go through it?
Has anybody not gone through this yet?
This isn't our one. This is the um
determining if a token has been used,
yes or no.
Anybody feel like doing it?
I feel like having fun.
This is fun, right?
You guys are so quiet. You guys are
quiet.
Why?
This is the fun stuff.
This is why we're here.
This is fun.
Hey,
>> hey there. Hey there.
How you doing?
Okay. All right. I'm gonna have to point
somebody.
You guys are so quiet. I have no idea
why you guys are so quiet over this
stuff.
Hey drum.
I think I want to do this today. I think
should lead. Um JJ, are you in front of
your computer?
I need. Okay. It has to be done by
someone who has successfully done a
token because you don't you haven't done
a token. This won't work. So, put a one
in the chat if you've done your token
already.
>> Are you asking for the bear token? The
bear token.
No, it it's the lambda has to issue the
token.
>> Well, a token issued,
>> right? So, are you
>> So, you're asking for the bearer token
issued by the lambda, but are you asking
if they have successfully
>> attached the No. Well, I understand
that, but are you also asking if it if
they've been able to authenticate
through authenticate after attaching the
authorizer to the API gateway?
>> They don't need to do that because this
this lambda checks whether or not it's
been used or not.
>> Okay. So, it's just just generate the
bear token. That's okay. That's
it.
Chewbacca wants to do this lab. Sorry.
So you can't do it. Okay. Chewbacca
wants to go to cultur.
>> He does want to go to tour.
>> You know what that is, right?
>> Yeah. I know what is black. No, I I know
you know what it is, but do you know
where it is?
>> Yes. Why? Why are you asking?
>> What? I'm just ask just asking
>> na. All right.
>> I don't know. You guys are so You guys
are some of my best students and you
guys are shy. I don't know why. All
right. Um this is the lab. Here is the
walkth through. Is this right? Sore sore
is going to be Saturday.
>> So, here you go. We haven't done sin
blood.
>> Um, we kind of done sled blood every
time this Oh, um, so you guys know, we
will be doing redesigns.
Um, later on I'm in the class process of
doing another redesign of Seir one and
Seir Foundations.
Um, we want to move the class more
towards not having like one class three
times a week, but maybe having um two
classes one time a week kind of speed
things up. Uh, so
trying to think about how that would
work, but we I do want to go I can if I
have two classes a week, then I can go
faster.
So, we'll see how that's possible to do.
maybe have two classes, then have a next
one as a review where we would do what
happened either one of those classes.
That's something like that.
We'll see what it happens. But yeah,
it's we should be moving like that.
Okay. Uh Kirk, I'm going to go ahead and
let you share your screen and have you
do the walk through. Um who wants to
help Kirk? Who wants to help Captain
Kirk?
Do I need to appoint three first
officers for Captain Kirk?
Yes, you need to appoint three first
officers. Not they're all shy. Okay,
good. Coach, you're doing you're doing
pretty good. Let's help you help. Uh
Bash Cloud, fine. You help him.
Uh who else do I want to do?
Anunda, you can help him.
Okay.
So, I'm going to sit back and I'm sit
here and watch though. I will be
watching. I want to see how well he does
to this.
Hello. And I will drop something here.
Here you go.
In the background.
Okay. So, he's doing nothing.
>> Oh,
I'm I'm going to give it a try. So, uh
I just got to run that Python script.
Give me a moment. Let me
get my stuff set up.
I'm sorry. I got I got to set this up
again. I I need to make a uh
take up
>> because I'm what I'm doing is the uh I I
got like a function because I get tired
of running the uh virtual environment.
Yeah,
>> if anybody has any notes or anything
because I'm getting kind of tired of it.
Uh
if there's a way to activate a virtual
environment without uh it's like I have
to run it every time. I have a function
doing it right now, but uh if anybody
has any tips on that, let me know.
>> Save it in your uh is this uh you're on
Z, so you're on Mac.
Yeah,
>> it's in Zshell, but it's I I put it like
where it's positive. So, it'll run in
bash, too.
>> You can uh we can set up as an
environmental variable. So, if you save
it to your path, you can save an alias
that will
>> I got you. I think that's Aaron
mentioned something like that. I didn't
look into it.
>> Not sure exactly what is with Cell. I
know it's a bash rc file with the the
bash I'm guessing z might be zshell
rc.
>> Do you need just the command or
>> to make you
>> Yeah, I'm good. I get it. I'm just
taking note.
You might have to go to
All right. I don't know.
I know what I was working. It was this
one.
We'll
export this.
Put that in a file too.
Pretty sure that
I don't
Is this
something?
>> What's that?
>> No. Unless
I got the password.
Okay, now I got my uh
access token. I actually I didn't uh I
don't think I ever fixed these with the
uh
with the curls here. One of them was
giving access when it shouldn't. But uh
you you want me to do anything with
these tokens? You want me to curl or run
them through something else?
>> Yeah, you can tell.
I'm
>> Yeah, I just curl it and test it on
Python. I think it was the node one
giving me trouble
or no, it was the Python user had access
to which they shouldn't. I I'll do this
one first.
>> Go ahead.
>> And uh
I know we changed something. I think I
used the I instead of a H. I don't
remember that.
>> So, you got your token. Okay. So, now
you can proceed with the lab.
>> Okay. I did a I
am
>> It might have been something I broke
that I didn't fix last time. Let's see.
H I think I know part of it. Uh it would
be
I can see
>> Is that why uh it's probably right there
where
>> Oh no, I changed it. I ran I ran the
wrong uh I see what I did. I ran the
wrong script. I modified it to C7
flavor. It It was something in this this
one here. I don't remember what it was,
but I
I uh updated it. So last class I would
have fixed it here. So I'm I'm gonna try
this one first.
Let's try again.
There we go. Okay.
my export.
That was
export.
Do it. Yeah.
All right.
I don't know if I
updated the script to take these.
Hope I did.
You can you can just fix it if you want.
Maybe I shouldn't export it using
Oh, that's
exported.
There we go. Now I don't got
um
All right. So just the these should work
or or as far as like
yeah that's access granted but my node
here I saw other people I think maybe
y'all could help me. I saw some of y'all
had this to deny, but at this point,
mine when I curl that node as Python
user with that token,
it uh it it keeps granting access. So
that that's where I'm at with it right
now.
And uh I had time I've been trying to
catch up on the other class. I didn't I
had
>> You got the You got the token. Go on to
the next lab.
>> That's fine. Oh, you're not concerned
about the the privileges here with that
user being
>> No, the the next lab is to check whether
or not you have a token or if you've
used it. So, if you've issued it, you're
good. Don't worry. Go on to next.
>> All right. So, that's the new stuff you
gave us, right?
>> Yep.
>> Okay.
Oh, I did something like Okay, let's see
what's going on. So, create a Dynamo DB
table. Yeah. Yeah. I actually I had did
a
another lab on my own and I made a DB
table and it uh
man I got to remember what it even did.
I mean
>> hey Kirk, heads up on this one. Your um
nomenclature for table name and
everything's got to be exact for the
slab.
>> Okay. Appreciate it.
>> Mhm. And then, oh yeah, it remembered
the session so it could uh log the user.
>> You can't have a dank table. Sorry.
>> So, we're gonna
Oh, boy. So, we're going to call it
token tracking partition key token ID.
All right.
tracking
partition key
ID token ID
string
no sort key
opacity
am I missing
Well, I was already there. Listen
deeper.
>> There we go.
>> Yeah. Okay.
Make this table there.
Is is that the correct key you want or
>> Yeah, he wanted the uh
that was just a tag I put to I don't
think he gave me instructions on
tagging. I just wanted to put a tag on
it.
But it was the uh token track and token
ID was the key.
Pretty sure
partition key, token ID.
Yeah, I got the right table key.
Partition key and token tracking.
So we got to fix the get token pipe.
this script.
Oh, that that's this script I'm dealing
with here
to get token script
unless No, we don't have a lambda doing
that.
Pretty sure that's the script. Let me
pull up my lambdas.
Okay.
17.
So the get token you buy is the one that
you run down.
Well, see you got it saved to C7.
>> Yeah. Yeah, I got it on this other
screen here. I'll pull it over. I'm
assuming that's what
>> that's our token. Uhhuh.
>> So,
I guess this is the modification.
I should do it this way.
So when we run the script,
it should create a dynam record.
So we might want to run the script
again.
>> Uh what's that batch?
>> I was saying when you run the script, it
adds a Dynamo DV
record
to the table.
Oh yeah.
>> Yeah, that's what I'm assuming. Yeah.
>> So
import time. Got that.
Okay.
Now,
let's take this block.
Now, where do we want to put this?
>> Go to the end of the script.
>> I'm I'mma read through this first.
>> Got you.
Oh, that's just setting
variable.
So, it has to be
well token ID isn't
it's a string.
Okay. So, this is the action.
So, we should probably do it after we've
uh
authenticated.
Let's decline.
I should have studied this again. I I
got it like
keep scrolling down, Kirk.
>> So, y'all want it after the curl?
>> Yeah, I'll put it. Me personally, I'll
put it after that last curl examples
using access tokens bit.
Yeah, that makes sense. I just like to
go through everything and it just clicks
for me better when I think about it.
I don't know what to
what it was
writing. Oh, it's just writing token.
>> Yeah, I think you just probably put like
update token.
I do something like that.
>> Oh, didn't we do something like this?
Hold on. Hold on. I'm looking at this.
We
Oh, I know what it's saying. I I want to
I want to I want to see something.
Uh
it's got the same thing.
Pull this one over. This might be
different.
Oh, no. That was with the groups. Okay.
I could have swore I saw something in
code we had already.
That's probably what I'm thinking about.
That's different.
ID username issued used
token use not you okay okay is it's diff
it's taking different uh
elements of the token okay all right
I guess that's it we can run it
Let's give it a try.
I messed something up.
Oh, what's going
Huh?
>> Are you trying to open up?
>> Oh, it's up here. It's telling me Oh,
did I Did I Yeah.
I don't know what I did up here. Yeah.
Oh, geez. Let Let me Let me go back. I I
just I got a typo at the top near the
import. I don't know what I did or what
I pressed. So,
there it is. I typed something in
terminal
or thought it.
>> Yeah, I fixed it. And then I'll comment
that.
Yeah, that should that should do it.
Why does it I keep pressing stuff,
y'all. Like when I do CC and terminal, I
don't know how it's ending up over here.
Um,
all right. I saved it
in my terminal. Not even going to press
it.
>> Are you trying to execute that script?
>> Are you? Yeah.
>> You're opening it though.
>> You know what you're doing, bro. I don't
want to really jump.
>> I'm already
>> I'm like, yeah, you already opened it to
go. No.
Let him land. Like, you know what I
mean? I want to let him land. I want to
let him, you know what I mean? See,
>> I just let him keep on going. I WAS
WATCHING IT. I was like, "Okay."
>> No, it's cuz I'm I'm using my uh
>> I'm using the arrows and it's it's
spoiling me. If I typed it, I would have
known. There we I'm sorry. Okay. There
we go. But it's it's something I didn't
Okay. Okay.
Well, something's deprecated.
Daytime.
Make a note of that.
Uh I mean that publication warnings
don't generally break things, right? I
mean scheduled for the future.
>> It's just an expiry notice for now.
Yeah.
>> Yeah. I should take this off.
>> It's that um
>> but the
>> the bracket the
bracket.
>> So this here line 208.
Oh, I just have an issue.
208.
Let's see what's
running as a function.
That makes sense.
I guess
I don't need coins.
Something
doesn't look like candy, is it?
So maybe
Yeah, that's B3.
Oh, I think part of the Well, I don't
know if that's a
Maybe it's a region.
Uh, quite possibly because I'm running
them. Well,
US West
can uh
That could be it. Um, wait. You could do
it in here.
Need
Let me try that. Man, I know I got that
code somewhere else. So, I'mma Google it
for now.
Go to three.
Yeah, he's just reaching
Oh, it's up here already. No, that's not
the region. It's already right there in
US.
That's in there with the T. It shouldn't
matter. That's global.
Listen,
return
as I'm like, what's default region
default.
So
>> it's it's on west too. But the uh I
don't think that should matter because
this
or does it? I don't think that matters
because it'll it'll run it in here.
Try exclam.
Say that again.
>> Try exporting the region when you run
the script. So if you actually just set
your AWS
region in all caps
>> equals US East one.
>> You don't you don't need to explore
that. You could just literally just put
AWS.
>> No, I'm sure. Okay.
>> All capital
AWS.
>> Is that what it is? No, that's need.
>> No, just AWS region no space equals
>> and then uh put in just US East one. No
uh it's not it's a string. You don't
need to put it's a string just put us
east.
>> So noation
>> so like
>> just equals just yeah just the value but
you have to put USC correctly. So it has
to have dashes. So US dash east-
run the command is
yeah still complaining.
I'm gonna keep reading about how this
function works.
And if you got any ideas, let me know.
>> Hey, Kirk, real quick, can you go back
to the terminal and paste the error in
the chat?
>> Yeah.
Got to get this
chat pulled up.
All right.
>> All right. So,
>> too many characters. I'm going to um
You've already got a you've already got
a value for AWS region US as well. So
that's why you didn't do anything. So
try this command.
That's what we want to really set is a
default.
>> Uh give me just a second.
I'm just going to put this error in a
text file because the u it's too many
characters.
All right. I put it in the chat in the
text file.
>> That's the command you want me to run,
Dash.
>> Uh, yeah. Give me GoPro.
Uh just put an equal sign.
>> Just equals US hyphen.
>> Yeah,
>> it's just off.
>> No, afterwards you need to No, you need
to just run it all.
You don't really need to run something.
>> Oh, you just want to try it as a one
shot? I'll just copy and paste.
>> No, no, no. You can run it like this.
It's fine. You already set the default
between
you can just run it like that.
>> No.
It looks like you pay closer attention.
It looks like it's the exact same.
Nothing changed.
Core
factory.
Okay.
Refresh.
That's a good point, Daniel. Um,
let me read this closer and then I'll
look at the Python script, too.
resource not found when calling the put
item operation
requested resource not found.
So
token dash tracking is my table.
I'm thinking uh
let me let me just confirm that first
and I'll tell you what I'm thinking.
Uh we got our table here.
So, I I don't think that's the issue,
but um
I'm thinking it's something to do with
these resources here that the function
is calling from uh
I guess from Boto3 and and it's using
these libraries
and uh I'm guessing it's a resource
there. I don't know because it says
erroractory dot
Bodto core. So I'm guessing that's the
library error factor. I don't know.
But uh this this looks like some stuff
possibly going on with the the function
itself
calling stuff from the library
which I guess we can't see
because it's abstracted here.
So I'm I'm going just keep reading.
Maybe I'll learn a little. Let me close
my I'll learn a little more about u
about that function.
They have a syntax. Let's see if we
match the syntax.
I'm going to do response
that's the table
output
item equals
just copy this part so I can see it
Never mind. I'll look at it over here.
That's a key value. So, it has to be too
strong.
That's it.
I'm getting lost reading this.
Are you going to
a map of attributes, which is what we
have Here token attributes,
you know, part of the issue I think is
going on. I think uh this is just a
hunch.
The uh that table is only asking for the
token ID, but it's trying to put these
other
values in. And there's no place in the
database for it. Like if you got this
key here, it can write this value, but I
don't think it can write username and
all that other stuff in there.
Um,
I made this bigger.
Matter of fact,
I'mma take a look at at some because I I
was messing around with
and I had
gosh the table.
>> You have more than one account.
>> Yeah, I got another AWS account. Could
you double check that
we're not trying to do something on one
and then checking the other one to to
see if it worked?
>> You mean like like I'm uh applying it to
the wrong one?
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, no. I'm not even logged in on it.
It's just something I made with uh Yeah,
I got it there because it's it was a lab
or something and you can do some IM
stuff, but it's it's nothing I actively
use.
I mean, I don't think I'm even sign Oh,
no, I am. Am I?
Yeah, I'm not even signed in because
they got it now where you can switch
back and forth, but I I don't use the
other one like that.
record created
goes up.
Let's see what
So you got the same thing going back.
You just added this here. Oh, well, let
me save it first.
And then uh
>> no what I was saying is that um when I
run the script news it gave that to me.
So I think it's already been taken into
account only my entries that are going
into the Daniel table.
So, I'm not sure if that's my username,
but if it just usually
Yeah. Yeah, that was my
username.
Yeah.
sexually.
Oh, the thing that I was saying was
there we go. You edit the
attribute.
Yeah, I'm going try this.
So,
it's going to be looking for username.
That's going to be a string.
Could that be a key though
or attribute?
Oh, that's the attribute of this token
ID.
I don't know if that's what we want to
do.
It's a it's not a attribute of the
attribute. It's attribute of the
username is attribute of the token, not
an attribute of the token ID. So that's
that's
and I I think it might have to be a
partition key and each key will take a
value that you can write to it. So I
have to add another
I'm going just try to make another
database
just to run a test.
back into
Oh, no.
It retrieves items from your table,
collects data.
So, key.
Maybe not. Let me go back.
So, maybe uh
It doesn't have attributes at all.
That's the
Another
just clipping stuff.
Oh, I cannot play that anymore.
I literally can't find what all is here.
Action
create.
Yeah, I'm going just try to create items
here.
It'll be
it doesn't work. I'll delete it.
Can I do that? Yeah. Okay. That's just a
username.
That's going to be a string
issue that
the date time should be a string.
What would it be?
I sat
Oh, that's bullying.
value.
I don't know.
Oh, these are going to No, that's not
what I want to do.
Let's see what's going here.
Thanks, Kevin.
Oh, I was just trying that the uh
Oh, I wonder.
Hey, Kevin, can you tell me so you're
taking your token attributes in
manually?
>> No. Um,
>> I found these um
>> cuz I was trying to do something
similar, but then I was thinking about
it. The uh this function is supposed to
write to the table
and I thought
putting values on the attributes or
maybe is that giving it an example of
the attribute
when you do that?
>> Um, click on explore table items.
Yep.
Oh, okay. I see yours is blank.
Yeah, I was asking though cuz cuz I was
trying to do something similar cuz what
I saw was uh right here.
This this is like the schema
>> of the uh of what we're trying to pass
through.
>> So, I thought maybe the table was
rejecting it because it only has token
ID. So, I'm guessing that's And I
literally I put these same uh keys here.
>> Yeah.
>> But when I put false, I got to the end
and I was like, "Oh, it wants me to give
them values,
>> but I thought values were supposed to be
written to them." So, I had canceled it
out.
>> Okay.
>> I mean, let me try it anyway. I I'll put
values. So, you're putting your actual
token values over there. Are you talking
about the uh the values for username and
token ID?
Not token ID, but are you talking
username issued all the attributes for
the token here? If you go on the
database,
>> if you go up on the script on that
script and it says go up
some point touches that basically touch.
That's why you have to
>> Oh, is it
Oh no, it's token ID. Username.
>> Yeah, you see that username is defined.
>> Token ID is there and then
there you go.
>> Yeah, it's right here.
>> It pulls it from when you enter it. You
enter the client ID, you enter the
username, you enter the password, and it
then encapsulates that within like that.
board. They couldn't use that lab,
I'm guessing.
>> No, that that's what's happening.
The uh I was curious about this side.
>> I don't know why it's not putting the
item. I don't know why, but it's
supposed to.
>> Uhhuh. Yes. It's supposed to write it
there because you put it here, right?
>> Because that's Yeah, I had that as well.
>> Uhhuh. But then my uh
my uh my thought process though was
because I'm guessing if you put it here,
it should write it. But then I was like,
well, maybe the table needs it defined
over here. But that that kind of didn't
make sense because this is me adding
stuff and I had to give it a value.
So I uh that's like manually entering
literally. Oh, you're literally creating
an item. So, when you do this, we're
just manually putting an item,
which means you need both pairs,
but we we're trying to get it to
have Bodo do it.
Um,
>> right.
>> And and everything Bash said is true
about this here, this here, and then
that's the boolean.
So,
I don't know.
>> What you're saying is basically you need
a schema for that information within the
your table.
>> That's what I was thinking, but you
don't need a schema because it's Dynamo
DB.
>> Yeah. So, I mean, I don't know. I
honestly I don't know why it's not right
right now. I like your process. I like
your troubleshooting process. like the
way you're kind of you're thinking from
every single corner. But um I really
don't know why it's not
>> it's all right.
>> Figure it out.
>> Yeah. And so yeah, Dynamo DB doesn't
care.
>> When was the last time you ran your
script?
>> Uh let me see.
Show my
eyes
like 8:13.
He's still about 13 minutes ago.
>> Okay.
>> Try to do this. Yeah. Can you rerun that
last command that I put in the chat, but
just run it all as one line?
>> Mhm.
>> Yeah, please try that.
Because I said it doesn't make a
difference, but it might actually make a
difference.
>> I see. Yeah. This one here, right?
>> Right.
>> Seriously.
>> Did it?
>> I knew it. I knew it.
>> Okay, let's let me break this down. Hold
on.
because basically it has to run within
one command. That's the reason why.
Yeah. So you're passing values to the
script and then executing.
>> I think that's the reason. I'm just
wondering why it's not uh
taking that as
>> it's because it's because you created
basically you're you're executing
your your uh environment is basically
using your default region which is US2
>> and then you're trying to essentially
the the the value for your uh I think
the table
is created in US one right so
>> so you got to you run the global stuff
in the global
>> you have to run it from the right region
as well. You have from the same region
as the resource
>> that's why
yeah
it's getting it from my environment. I
literally could Yeah. My bad. The uh
Thank you. Like like if I uh I just
>> Yeah. I couldn't figure out why it
wasn't running because I was like that's
wrong. Yeah. I was like
>> it's the simplest thing. If that's not
working, then it's not working. But I
could do a battle, but
>> right.
>> No, it's literally I could just set it
here because it's it's grabbing it from
my environment. I don't know why it is.
So,
well, we know that'll work. Bam. Now, if
we do this
Oh, come
>> error.
>> I figured out that No, no, no, no. You
don't need to do that. What you what you
need to do is just set your default to
the same set your default region within
your terminal to the same region. US set
us see if you have another
as long as you set your default region
correctly
>> right now your default region. So if you
do in
a
>> Yeah, it's the Yeah, the config thing.
If you
>> I just had that up to
>> Is this one here?
>> Yeah, that's the issue
that allows it to run because you're
setting for specific
Just put them both.
Thank you, sir.
Opening this. Let's see.
>> Python.
>> I'm not gonna spend 20 minutes doing
that.
>> No, it's not.
>> It's cuz it's not about the It's not
about the the default region in the
script. It's about the different
premium,
you know, it's it's something with the
environment. The uh for now,
I'm not going to worry about it. I I'll
leave a note though.
>> What's the default region of your CLI?
>> It's west two. Okay.
>> And that that was causing me issues.
Or you could literally just change the
script to say what's breaking change. So
I wouldn't recommend that, but it's easy
to just change your be. You can always
switch.
>> Yep.
>> Yes. Well, we got that.
>> All right. So,
work the token use.
Oh, let me see what Lambda's saying.
Oh, I'm tripping, man.
That's not fun.
There we go.
>> Just do this. Yeah, do this. Before you
do anything else, just do export.
Just write export.
>> Oh, yeah. That's how I'm going to do at
first.
Oh, boy. Just do export.
>> AWS default region. No, no, no. Default
region.
>> Oh, I was going to do both.
>> Oh,
let's just do default because then it
doesn't matter. You can you can do both.
You can do both. Now run the script. Now
you can run the script.
>> Mhm.
>> Just run it normally. Now you can run
it. There we go.
>> Yeah. I appreciate that.
>> Uh what else can you do? I don't know
why it's still
>> telling us.
>> Oh, cuz we didn't tell it to. We didn't
tell it to.
It's uh
we don't have any prints. That That's
something I noticed. I just wasn't
worried about it because it didn't work.
We don't have any output here that is
it's not printing anything.
So, do we want that? I guess print.
>> You can if you want. It's not necessary.
You could check and see if you've
actually
table
maybe.
>> Oh, yeah. We could do that, too. I was
going to start writing it. The uh Yeah,
we could check the table.
explore table items. There we go. We
wrote to it three times.
>> Four times.
And then I want to maybe play around. We
could do like a basic print.
We can say uh print.
We're going to use the colors. I guess
magenta or green.
I'm going to say great
Uh, let me try.
Let's not use this. It's going to be
Oh boy. table.
No, that's an function
item define.
Oh boy.
I'm just do it the way I know.
Let's get Yeah, it's item
table item equals.
Um yeah.
table item
dot
I think it's why is terraform stuck in
my head use
equals false
>> if you want to just print it um if you
just want to print it I'll put it in the
chat
>> okay I was trying to do like a
conditional where it could tell me if
it's used or not without going to the
>> Okay.
>> Yeah, I was going to put that as the sec
as the second part
or something kind of like that.
>> I think we're actually going to make a
separate number that checks if it's
being used.
>> Oh, well, I won't do that. I won't do
that in the Python. So, uh yeah, because
then I can just because I just wanted it
in the CLI.
I don't I don't mind I don't mind.
And uh I'm gonna just steal your print.
So thank you.
>> I'm probably over engineering to stop
me.
>> No, this is how you're going to learn.
That's lowerase table.
We're going to lowerase table. Oh, wait.
How can I do?
>> Yeah, something definition
is format with the let's just issue
that.
>> I pull up this. Oh man, I'm trying to
remember how to reference a dictionary.
That's confusing.
Oh [ __ ] that's basic
print used.
But we don't know if it's We don't want
that
cuz we don't know if it's used.
Oh, wait. We're hard coding.
Oh, wait. Let me
>> I'm confusing myself, y'all.
>> Yeah, Bash, you were saying like a
lambda's going to
>> uh Yeah, and we're going to create a
lambda. We're going to create a
detection lambda.
Uh but before that, we're going to move
on to phase three cuz we're done phase
two now. Um
>> okay,
>> so phase three
when lambda receives validation request
update DV update previous Lambda with
this. So there's a link there. You want
to click through to that link or update
token.
It's the one above
you face toate
previous. Okay.
Update your previous.
Wait, which
>> this would be on your iPhone number one?
>> Okay. Yeah,
this one here.
And that's
make sure
they
welcome
April. should be able to just add it at
the end, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Or would that shouldn't cause any issue.
>> I had other issues, but
yeah, that's that's just
okay.
Is it ready?
>> It's just updating the token.
>> It's updating the token to make it used.
Okay, let's see.
All right.
saying basically later on
you can pass token id one of the headers
uh and it actually prints this out for
you when you run the script later it
will actually give you both values so it
will give you a cloud to be um using
access
right here.
>> That's the end. All right. So, now next
step is phase four. We're going to need
to create a new lambda
and we going to need here.
>> All right, we'll do that.
>> Did you deploy this one? This one?
>> Yeah, I deployed it. I'll create just
Yeah, that's good.
>> Should we test it?
>> Oh, yeah, we could. Well, it's going to
update the token, but do we have
anything to tell us if it's used?
This isn't doing
Oh, I'm tripping, man. testing it here.
My brain is fried. So that I don't have
a testament. Oh, we have to make a
testament then.
>> Yeah.
>> Um,
>> yep. Do I have
>> top right um yellow test button
check you can check the log details
>> well it didn't fail so
>> it'll run whatever we just All
right. So
the next phase
make that lambda. Okay.
Create.
>> Yeah, that's true, Kevin. Thank you.
Uh
use token detecting. How about
>> uh just make sure that you take that off
of node unless you want to be
the runtime.
>> You still have your runtime in node.
>> Oh, I'm I'm not even messing with that.
I'm trying to find where I'm at on this
site here.
>> You're on phase four.
>> You're on phase four. Yeah.
>> Yep. the detection.
>> Okay.
>> I'm I'm I'm with y'all. I'm just
processing the
>> the
take your time. If we're Russian, you
just just
Okay. Yeah. We'll just I was just
interested in seeing what it does.
And then we got
That should not
listen to det.
Wait, shouldn't we have a handler for
this?
Yep.
That's a good catch.
I'll just
Kevin, I know you previously got u I
think you went past this previously,
right? I think you went to the audience.
>> Yeah, we're about the same part. Um I
think the issue I had was um permission
spaced. Now that I'm reviewing today's
logs,
>> is it imm.
>> Yeah, I'll Yeah, I can copy um the ever
message.
Is that all?
Oh, that's nasty.
there like a terraform FM2 version for
London
for you.
It doesn't have a return,
but I guess something like this.
It has to
change.
Oh, that's what Kevin's dealing with.
Okay. Oh, we got to get a lamb
permission and do something. Let me
come back to that area.
I didn't read what this was doing. It's
the table scan. That's a function. I'm
guessing it doesn't have permission.
So
yeah, that's what we thinking. Thank
Thank you. TRQS
that a read permission
every item in this table.
Yeah, I think it just needs read
permissions on the table.
I was trying to scan it.
Yeah, that looks like a table read.
Yeah, I think it just needs read
permissions.
So, uh,
oh, matter of fact, we got that roll
here.
I can't do this.
Oh, there it is.
I'm going just do it in line.
>> Yeah, it finds out.
What's this?
Oh, that's the policy I'm trying to do.
>> I mean, I think you only need DB. I
don't think right now.
>> What's that?
>> So, I was saying I think you only need a
DB
around.
>> Are you talking about right here?
>> No. No.
>> I know the commercials
re the options
>> in the Say that one more time.
>> Basically, TQ has put a policy that
definitely work. They'll definitely
work. But I was saying out of those
right now, I think the only one we read
is
You could just actually you know what
just I was just trying to be like least
privilege but um yeah you could just do
>> right right I got you curious about what
items
>> could be yeah I got you on the same page
because I thought it was only a read
right it's scanning it's not writing
anything so we don't but I can add it in
line and test it and remove whatever we
don't need
>> I mean you can give it to your lambda or
you can Just attach this person to your
user to your
your user essentially.
All right.
I am using
Oh, no. That that doesn't that wasn't
going on there.
Are you saying cognito user?
>> No, it's in you.
But the only reason
>> cuz I'm the uh remember it's not a
it's the lambda doing it.
So I would think the lambda need that
needs that permission.
>> Oh yeah.
>> I'm just Yeah, I think it's here. That
it
Oh, I had to open it. That's what it is.
Okay,
now I uh now I'm going to add the
permissions that uh
PIQS just gave me.
It's more comprehensive in here.
>> What if Hey,
>> what am I doing? What am I doing? If you
just attach it, if you just attach that,
you can go to your lambda. So you can go
to your unused token detector longer and
then click configuration permissions
execution ro and then you can take back
permissions.
Yeah, that that's what I was doing. See
this this is what I was trying to what I
was doing here. Um,
>> wait. Go back.
>> But it has you do it like as a modular.
>> Yeah. What's up?
>> Uh, go back to the unused tech.
Go back and still
Right. Go to the execution. I think
maybe
it
>> Yeah, that's what I just did. When So
when you looking at something else?
>> Oh, it's all good. Yeah, it it it it
like kind of makes you go back into IM
to do the full thing.
>> Oh,
>> and then if you do it the other way you
showed me, you could put like one of
them in the little things here, but uh
it it won't let you do the the full
JSON.
And so
>> what if what if you click on the
execution ro name?
>> Let's try that just so we know. So
>> roll that name here.
>> Yeah. Now you can add permissions.
>> That's what I uh So if I do this
>> right.
Yeah, that's that's what I was looking
for. And we'll see
>> that's
that basically say we go back here which
is why it's annoying if you edit
that same button here.
>> Right. Right. Takes you to the same
place.
>> Yeah. Yeah. It just pushes you back out
to uh to I am. So um here app permission
per is is the same thing.
And uh that's kind of annoying but
whatever.
So, I had it here.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. There's a bunch of different ways
to do the same thing.
>> I was looking at a different part of the
rumble group. So, actually the one we
really need about this one is scan.
very best to just do it's best to be
missing right now too restricted.
>> So we can test you can always tighten it
up permissions on the back end or the
test.
Yeah.
close. Not as close.
I need a comma after version.
Ah,
>> thank you.
No, now it's
>> You've got two versions there. Two
versions.
>> Oh, I did not delete it.
>> Okay,
let's start now.
>> Yeah, maybe it'll let me show.
>> I think you still have an error. On the
previous page, it said error.
It took everything away.
>> There we go. Oh, um, also remove that
last comma on line 15.
Just refresh.
Yeah, it does not matter. It doesn't
matter if you're either version off the
top. You can have the version in the
bottom. So you can just kill exactly the
one that killed.
>> Why is it Oh, I didn't notice that one
at the
>> Yeah. So just
>> Okay, that's that's give me a hard time.
Yeah, I just leave it at the bottom
then.
>> I I didn't realize he had one at the
bottom.
>> It's still trying to
>> just
You need a comma. You need a comma after
that last You actually do need that
comma on line 14 after that brace.
Yeah. Online 14. Yeah. Put that comment.
>> Oh, that whole uh list.
Is that it? Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> I hate JSON,
>> man. I I don't know. I just downloaded
uh
>> Man, there's something on the CLI that
lit it. I forget what it's called, but
uh I run it through there when I'm doing
it on my on my computer.
>> Uh give it a name.
>> Uh just put like
>> what's the name of that table? Read
token tracking.
>> Token tracking detector scan.
I'm going to call it token token
tracking.
>> What's the policy? I'll just call it
read token track.
>> Yeah, you can call it
>> the main action.
>> Oh, cuz that's a function. Yeah, that's
what it's doing.
Table scheme.
token tracking
>> scan
>> table scan token tracking. There we go.
Something like that.
>> Yeah.
>> And then uh we'll create this.
Okay.
Cancel out of this.
Cross our fingers.
Access den scan operation.
Not authorized to perform DB scan on it.
>> Maybe just redeploy. Did you Did you
redeploy the lambda?
No, I didn't.
>> Makes a difference. But let me see.
>> No, I didn't update my AR. My AR is
different than
the IQ.
That's the issue.
>> Also, also do me a favor. Um, go to your
unused tokens.
Now go to configuration
and then environment on the left
and then edit
environment
and then we got a token table.
>> No capital.
Oh, that's
>> Thank you.
>> You can just leave that.
>> Yeah. Just redeploy.
So
I got to put my actual iron in that
policy.
>> Oh, in the policy on,
>> huh?
>> Your your own. You put it on.
>> I never put mine. I just I just blindly
submission.
Let me go here.
Edit that.
This is my
>> You have to edit it.
>> I'm like, did it change?
USC.
>> What's that?
>> Is it? No, no, no. I should
No, no.
>> It doesn't even Oh, yeah. It's changing.
Okay. That one's mine. This one's mine.
We'll save it. We'll
come back here.
I don't like that red. Refresh.
All right, we'll give it a try.
There we go. Okay,
>> there you go. Token unused. Token
unused. Token unused.
It's actually giving you that looks.
>> What's next?
>> Oh, is that running it on every token?
That was what that for loop was doing on
all. Yeah, it's running every token.
beverage.
Um,
>> oh, you get alerts for every token.
>> So, for
uh
the tokens, alert token unused. Okay,
>> that's what that makes sense. So, I
closed it.
Oh, no I didn't.
Put this here.
Okay. So now
token use false older.
Oh, now that's the event bridge which
TIQS was uh mentioning earlier.
Oh, well maybe we want to y'all want to
least privilege this and take away some
of the permissions just to be
>> No proper.
>> No, I'm that kind of guy just so you
know.
>> No, I mean kind of play around with that
later on, but when you're
>> Yeah, I do it on my own time.
>> Yeah, while we're endto end testing, we
don't really want to restrict ourselves
too much.
>> We create a schedule, not a rule. Let me
go
show that
schedule. You just put schedule room
in put here, but I guess that's unusual
type.
Wait, hold on. We do. You don't know
much about We make a rule and run a
schedule on it. So, we need both.
Let's see. Select the target settings.
Let's see. Use token check.
Sketch
sketch.
Five minutes.
>> Mic check. Can you guys hear me? Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> All right. I'll take point from here.
Uh, you going to click
reoccurring schedule?
>> All right.
>> Oh, I'm sorry. It's uh
this one looks different. and go.
Okay.
Rate based schedule.
>> Yeah, that's what it
>> rate will be five minutes.
>> All right.
>> Everything else should be deep. Uh, so I
put the flex time window five five
minutes.
So I wanted to start checking it
five minutes after it is uh generated.
>> Oh, okay.
>> So the time frame is used if you wanted
to schedule a certain time to run the
event bridge. We're going to leave that
as default
in time frame.
So
>> what part of time frame? My bad.
>> Leave it blank.
>> Okay.
and go to next.
>> Your target is going to be lambda
and then your lambda function. You're
going to find yours that you used.
>> Everything else will be blank.
Click next.
And then everything here I think should
be blank. Let's scroll down a little
bit.
Uh
yeah, I use an a
execution row. Leave that as that. Click
next.
Now
check everything just to make sure that
you have the naming requirements, the
rate,
and your target is correct.
Yeah, it looks good.
So that event bridge runs that lambda on
a schedule. Yes.
Gotcha.
>> Yes. And every five minutes.
And from here, you're going to open up
your Cloudatch,
go to log management
and then find
the logs that is associated with that
lambda. So, I would sort it by time.
I was trying to find
that's just crazy.
>> Oh, you're drawing. I didn't even see
your drawing over there. Yeah. Thank
you.
And
>> just go into one of these streams here.
Most
>> recent one.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's the most recent one.
>> There you go.
Nice.
>> So, does that fire immediately and then
it it repeats every 5 minutes or do you
have to is there like a five minute lead
time for you to wait? So it's so for
mines
it'll automatically check it every 5
minutes. I don't know if it fires it as
soon as you create it. Uh
but
that's what it checks. So
what you can do to verify is is wait
five minutes. It'll
>> create some more logs underneath it and
see if these uh same tokens are um still
here unused.
>> That makes sense.
>> So, I have a screenshot of mine's up in
the chat uh that you can bounce yours
off of so you can see. But
I'm about 90% sure that that's correct.
I haven't gotten any confirmation yet,
but that's what I see.
>> I think you're absolutely right because
otherwise we might see it once since
we would have seen a fire
as a family loss. But thank you for
jumping in with me because I am a little
bit fuzzy on the event bridge part. I
haven't actually got this for a while. I
had issues with your off my
>> Oh, absolutely. Yeah.
>> I've been working up in the background
troubleshooting myself. That's how I was
able to figure out the permissions thing
uh with the AM for Dynamo DB. And it and
my last headache was this part here to
invoke it to have it trigger every five
five minutes. So,
>> okay.
>> Makes sense.
>> Nice.
>> Well, I mean, we're basically done. Uh
just have to kind of we find
information.
>> Well, we got that uh it's just like a
looks like a alert. Is that SNS maybe?
And I'm I'm we skipping the lizo step.
So we'll make alert.
>> So cloud watch log. That's what we got.
Oh, and then just make an alert. So
student one generated token. Ah,
okay. So we we can do like a like a back
test.
I think that's leaduding to that's
alluding to is that moral based
announcement? Uh
>> we got student one gener
two.
>> I think
I don't know how that's one of them got
somehow
having problems. So
>> how would you do that
>> alert? How would we do that alert?
That's that's interesting.
Would it
>> I'm thinking you need a payload on the
lambda. So it can pop up in the
cloudwatch logs and then uh SNS could
consume it
and then event bridge would trigger the
lambda
to run it drop the payload in the log
and then you SNS could consume it from
there. Am I thinking about that right?
So wait, vote me through the other.
>> So my thinking and maybe I'm making some
I don't know. I'm I'm thinking that the
uh lambda needs a return because right
now it doesn't have a return. So it's
it's not
it doesn't have a payload.
>> Wait, wait, wait. Just go to the cloud
watch live.
>> Oh, it Well, it does tell you it's
unused already.
>> Where am I?
>> Hold on. I I got two of I got two of
them. There we go. There we go. Here's
where we at. It does do this already.
>> Yeah. So, you can copy that. Yeah.
>> So, we could uh
>> you could just do alert token unused for
and then fill it for the rest if you
have multiple users.
>> Yeah, I have to look at this [ __ ] here.
>> Yeah, cuz this has a like a a certain
structure. Well, it's in the Let me
look. Let me just
>> hold on a second.
Do you mean that you just want to set up
like a email like a SNS?
>> Yeah, that's what I was thinking. So the
SNS would take that bit of the log and
just spit it back out.
>> Yeah, this SNS I think the V bridge will
actually spit it out to the SNS, I
believe.
>> Yeah, that's what I was kind of uh kind
of alluding to earlier. I I've added
stuff that it's already doing it here.
So, we could put that pattern
in there, I'm assuming.
And it would
it'd be unique for every uh user there
because every everyone's going to have
this structure here.
>> I don't know.
>> Yeah, you could uh you could you can
kind of watch all that.
>> All right.
Uh, what's that?
>> I was going to say no. Go ahead. Go
ahead. Go ahead.
>> No, no, go.
>> I'm thinking in in Cloudatch, you can
just create a metric filter.
>> Oh, that's even. Yeah,
>> which is right. which is for we did that
for previous
>> that's what we did with our
>> do y'all want to do that
>> I mean
it's up to you did it did we get the
event did the event bridge it it showed
up in the logs right the
>> yeah it popped up in the log
>> popped up
I mean If you if you want to do that,
then
why not? Try to set up. It's not within
the uh the spec, but I mean like
>> I don't think anybody's going to shoot.
>> Just type
>> Yeah, this is running.
>> Hold on a second.
In the filter events, just type alert
colon token.
I can stare through here cuz I started
clicking. Yeah. Oh, you're drawing
right. Oh, okay. Thank you. Thank you.
>> That that was Rob. Yeah, that's spot on.
>> Oh, thank you, Rob. What we looking for?
The
>> just type type alert colon.
>> Oh, that's that
>> space token.
It'll report used and unused or just
do
>> this is now it's going to report unused.
>> Here, hold on. It should be filtering
down further.
Let me see.
>> No, you can't.
>> I would just filter for just alerts to
be honest. Seven months, you know,
come back
or if you want to just uh click on that
bring link, learn more about filter
class.
>> Oh, you just want to click create
filter.
Basically, we want to we want to filter
it down so it only pops up the alert
when a a token is unused.
>> That's the trigger that that you want.
And then you just create
>> Yeah.
>> the filter. It's Oh, here it is. But it
has other stuff in there.
>> Once we're able to call just those ones,
however we do it, you just it'll use
that same thing and create metric
filter. Fill in what you need to fill
in. You're done.
>> All right. So, you want to do create or
>> I mean, yeah. I mean, you could you
could refine it a little bit so it's
only popping up the alerts and not
everything else. But
>> that's that's what I was uh that's what
I was wanting to do, but I was asking
what y'all what y'all trying to do
because y'all were coaching me through.
>> So, I would try. It doesn't take
semicolon.
I mean, I'm guessing it takes reax, but
I mean, if if you just link,
>> I'm sure that you will find some
documentation that's going to help you
out, right?
>> Try try putting quotes around the alert
just to see something real quick.
>> There we go. Documentation.
Thanks, Kevin. filter pattern.
Oh boy. And this reax.
Here we go.
Oh, I think you put the
percent sign on it.
Is that right?
No, I'm not. All right.
I thought it was this here.
You must surround your expression. The
whole expression.
I I had it on the wrong part. So it'll
be like alert
>> with the the colon. Now we can do it in
and it'll be token
>> token
>> maybe take a spectr
uh put it in uh quotes. So if you put it
in quotations
after the Yeah. after the Yeah. the
percentage sign. Yeah.
There you go.
Here's why these are even showing up. It
doesn't even have a
>> Hey, uh try setting up a Cloudatch
alarm. Um, so if you search for
Cloudatch or you if you click on
Cloudatch on the top left and then
open the alarms
um section
>> six million ways to die
what
create
You want to put a metric on there? Well,
we don't have a metric.
You just want to uh go through the
creation.
No, it requires a metric,
which is
what we're trying to do here.
Look at the tragic stuff.
Let me just see if this works for this.
It doesn't even like them.
>> Hey, try open it up. Open it up a folder
message for or click any one of the time
stamps for it.
>> I was going to say try one I just put in
the chat.
>> Yeah, I'm I'mma try what you said and
then coach I'll look into what you were
saying.
I don't know. See, cuz that that syntax
makes sense.
Reject pattern before and after the
pattern
using a reax pattern surrounded with
percent sign. The following code shows
an example of a filter pattern. That's
as simple as it gets. And we did alert.
All right, I'll try that out, coach.
Or is it the console being buggy? Cuz
the uh the syntax makes sense
even. Or or you want to try just a
simple one like uh
like this but with alert create the
filter. See if it works
>> because uh at this point it's it's just
making me think the console is tripping.
>> Yeah, I hear that. And also we could
just Yeah, just put a lot.
>> Uhhuh.
>> Yeah, we could expand.
>> So we want to create that filter, right?
>> Ah, this is where you were supposed to
put it. You were supposed to put it in
the other place.
It wasn't taking reject some of the uh
it just didn't understand the
>> Oh, it doesn't take it in the search bar
in household.
>> So, I don't think so.
>> I see. Okay. Okay.
>> So, now you can try like what put your
chart or chart.
>> Oh, look at that. That's the uh the
filter patterns right there. Oh, that's
>> See, that's kind of stupid. That's
stupid. It'll take your pattern, but
console doesn't drill it down.
Okay.
So, let's try this one first. We'll call
it.
>> Okay. So, it captures it.
>> Yeah, it took what we put in there,
which which because I would think the
whole point would be to just see if your
filter pattern works in here in console.
>> You create there's one underneath. You
see one underneath where it says uh
create new. So, you could put a new
metric normally. You can put a new
metric through one.
Oh, I I I was I think we're talking
about two different things, but this
here uh
we could we could try that. Let me give
it a We'll call this
token alerts and then
name spaces.
>> Yeah, we'll call it a name space. Yeah,
those come right.
>> We'll call this name space
token alert
all
the metric identify this metric. Oh no
no no no the name spacer is going to be
what is gauging what is measuring
uh
much
>> and then the metric name
I say
alert
>> electric
used and let me be more specific
>> and metric value.
>> You got to put in that filter pattern.
>> Is that right?
>> Yeah. This is where it's basically going
to
Let's see.
Put one.
>> Yeah, just pick pick a random one.
>> I think one was fun.
>> Okay,
I got to wrap my head.
>> Or or you you could put gotcha in there
or something.
>> Oh, it's just to evaluate. Oh, yeah. I
got
>> when it when when when the pattern is
matched up, it'll just give you a
catchphrase. So you can say found you or
whatever you want.
>> Uhhuh. Yeah. We'll just do one, zero,
true, off. I like that. Okay. So it's a
one.
>> And uh now we can run that alarm maybe.
Is that what we're trying to do with
this filter?
And then the alarm is what will push the
alert.
Refresh.
Let them.
Okay.
No, I can set you. Okay. What do we call
that?
just made the thing.
>> I think you called it used or unused.
Used or unused
token
>> token alert. There we go.
All right.
Using
se like that.
Okay. Creation
taste.
A minimum of one time. Is that what I
want to run on this?
It's greater than zero.
What y'all think about that?
Yeah, that's the only logic I see.
>> It's telling you I think it's saying to
how many times should it trigger?
>> Oh, okay. It'll trigger
>> statistic trust.
>> So, you want to add up the occurrences.
>> Yeah. for that metric because I I was I
figured uh instead of having it reach a
total like of all of them aggregated
>> it'll just be whenever it's
>> whenever it's triggered any just on the
first instance that it's triggered
essentially
>> yeah you could give up
>> and so we
No, actually you could put one.
>> Oh, but it's a period.
>> Yeah. So, if
>> I was saying the sum, it can only be it
can be just one. So, if it occurs any
time within a five minute period.
>> Oh,
>> do you get what I mean?
>> That's true.
>> Uhhuh.
>> So,
>> yeah, that makes sense.
>> Five minutes. Yeah. So, sum of one.
>> Yeah. And it's static. And then
condition.
>> Oh, that's just a it's just a uh
>> greater than zero.
>> Wait, is this still zero? Greater than.
>> You can also have greater or equal
>> uh greater equal one, but greater than
zero, right? You can put greater than
zero. Either way.
>> Yep. Yep. Yeah.
And then static data point
this one I can treat data that's missing
>> uh treat missing data is not reaching
>> yeah so it doesn't go off if it's
missing data
And then
add a notification
creating new topic.
Oh [ __ ]
top
create that topic.
I hope it's not tripping with the D fe
now.
All
right.
>> Just make sure your topic is make sure
your topic is correct.
Yeah, that's a topic.
Let's call it talking. Yeah.
Okay, I just got to confirm
and then
that's that should be it.
Let me uh
confirm on my email.
Yeah, I think you're good.
>> I'm just on my side trying to uh
trying to confirm that that email
All right, I confirmed it. That's
something
behind
something like that.
Just hit.
All right. So token alert using unused
tokens sum of one every five minutes
greater than no just greater than zero.
One data point to trigger
send the notification when an alarm
status. All right.
and just
hopefully wait for it to go up.
>> Yeah, it's still too soft to go up on
five minutes, right?
>> So,
you can check when you lost time.
Trying to give you something.
Oh,
>> in the logs just to see when it
My mom's just sitting about
here here
like three minutes ago.
>> So two more minutes.
>> Did you uh confirm the
Yeah. Yeah, I got it confirmed on my
>> I was doing it on my phone.
Changing some prices on
I better lock it in.
>> Try to refresh it.
>> There it is. It's in the line right
here.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. So, we can see if I got that
email.
>> We did. It's right here. Sweet. Well,
now you want a step further. A clap on
the back.
Clap on the back.
>> Yeah, that was good.
That was some good teamwork, y'all.
>> Maybe was.
>> Yeah, we just need to put the uh I mean,
from there you we we you could just
drill it down, I guess, with the uh
the metrics and then have one for used,
unused, and then put the kha messages in
there.
It's the same logic.
>> Yeah, you create the SMS.
>> Yeah, we got the we got the email and
everything.
>> Maybe I should.
>> We got the email.
>> Wow, you went above and beyond. I didn't
have SNS in there.
Very good.
>> We try.
>> You guys want to get jobs? Oh my god.
You guys want to be employed?
>> You serious,
Kirk? You actually want to get a job?
You want to be Captain Kirk? Are you
serious? Oh my god.
>> I thought you were supposed to be I
thought you're supposed to be dusty.
Must be dusty engineer.
>> That can be both.
>> I thought Waffle House.
>> That was it. Just Waffle House.
>> You're going to like this one.
>> You'll like this one, Theo.
>> I do like this one.
>> I was watch
>> What?
>> You were watching. And hey, kudos to you
guys as well. Um, I was trying something
on my own and I think I got the secret
hash to work.
So, this will be useful.
>> Oh,
the secret house has to work.
>> Yeah. So, I'll I'll I'll give you guys
my uh
>> Yeah. So,
>> so now it um so B so thank first off
thank you bash for the um for getting
the uh the shell command. So now I we
could have the secret h you could have
the app client secret put into the
terminal and I and I just got the access
token which is great. So that means I
can be able to authenticate with the
file. So, let me let me get you guys to
file. But, uh, we can use this because
now,
like you said, we want jobs.
So, let me get this to you guys.
>> I thought, especially you, Rob, you're
supposed to be dusty forever,
>> right? You're supposed to be dusty in
front of the station doing nothing.
Okay.
>> I I am supposed to be I'm supposed to be
practicing my evil laugh. Okay. I'm not
doing
>> the janitor at the law firm.
>> I am the janitor at the law. How' you
know? I That's how I speak. That's how I
learned his Spanish. Talking about the
wage. Picking up the garbage.
>> There you go. Yeah. What's wrong about
you in there?
>> Exactly.
>> And working at $3 an hour for the green
go.
>> Exactly. That's why my name is Green
Oberto.
God, this never stop. Okay.
>> So, yeah. So, y'all take a look at the
updated get token. Um tried to make it a
bit uh more flexible based on what Theo
based on Dio's original. Um you'll have
to put in a bit more for your inputs
because I I didn't want to just put the
set the default region. You have to know
what your region is. You have to put
your app client and then you can put
your client secret. I have not I have
not tested not using the app client
secret. So I I don't know if it works if
you don't use it. You probably have to
put in some conditional logic to catch
it. Um, but if you do want to use a uh
app tok uh app to uh app client secret,
then this works cuz then it can generate
the token and then you can go on from
there.
>> Nice.
And then and then that was the thing I
was really trying to focus on because
Dio said, "Hey, this insane security."
All right. I want insane security. I
want a joke.
Hey man, I'm trying to produce.
I'm trying to produce. Trying to get
trying to get this money.
trying. I We got to change.
>> You get $3.5 per hour.
>> That's it.
>> I can't even buy me I can't even buy a
taco in Boston. Come on, man.
>> You make them for the greenos. You don't
eat them.
>> I'm the green girl. What you
>> make them for the greenos?
>> Oh. Oh, the Oh, the real green goes.
There you go. Now I feel good. All
right. You guys did an excellent job.
I'm glad that you did more. I was just
trying to get to one section because
it's it's going into sore. So I just
wanted to get this one section done, but
you guys went really above and beyond.
So I'm actually very impressed. So this
SNS and SNS SQS would both be used with
Um, so way to go. I mean, very proud of
you guys. I just sat back and watched.
Like I said, I just s the whole time.
Um, excellent work. Um, guys, remember
if you have questions for me, I cannot
respond back on Facebook um on
Messenger. I can read your messages, but
I cannot respond back. So, um,
>> ping me on, uh, Discord. Okay.
Uh, yeah. Shout out to Kirk. Kirk, man.
Captain Kirk,
you took down the Romulence.
>> That was a team effort.
>> So, it was for that was So, that movie,
too. He didn't do it by himself.
Got the [ __ ] knocked out of him, but
he still knocked out the Romulons,
right? So, I think he did a great job.
>> Uh, I see a promising career for him.
Keep on going. Just don't give up. Um,
yeah, don't forget to tear down the
database. Take your notes, guys.
>> Please take your notes. This was there's
a lot of stuff going on, you know, going
back and forth. If if you can,
especially you, Kirk, take your notes
because you did a lot today. It was
great, but you but I I I saw that, you
know, you're getting yourself washed a
bit in the sauce, which happens, but you
got to take your notes to make it a bit
easier for yourself next time.
>> You also watch the video. Good.
Everybody should be watching the video.
People should be copying that video,
man. Taking it down, man. Just that was
that was a great video. So,
>> that was al that was also A1
troubleshooting, man. That's see and and
I'll share this, right?
Uh
so Jules, okay, I I'll tell you guys, uh
Jules is in employ for a job that is
offering him upwards of 400. Okay,
he had a coding exercise that he had to
do.
He had 45 minutes to finish the coding
exercise. He got half of it done, but
they decided to move on with him because
he was able to voice out exactly what he
was doing, what he was thinking and his
process.
And it's not and it and you know what
you did Kirk and what you did Bash and
and Tiqs and all the guys that helped
out being able to voice out that
process. That's more important than
getting the right answer because then
they understand he gets he understands
the the infrastructure. He gets what
we're trying to do here. He gets the
flow of how everything connects.
If you guys understand that, then that
is truly
what the companies are looking for
because they'll take a a a engineer
that's not the best, but if he if he can
understand conceptually what's happening
and how it connects from point to point
to point, then they'll take the time to
get it done. It doesn't have to be
immediate. You don't have to be an
answering machine, but you need to be
able to think and and conceptually
sort it out point by point. And you guys
did that and that was a great effort.
So, let's give you guys your flowers.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Those are your flowers.
That's good.
All right, guys. I'm impressed. I can go
to sleep now and be happy.
Um, guess again, you got for any
questions, go and reach out. Keep on
going, guys. Um,
we're about how many weeks away?
Four, three weeks away from class 7, the
next um, Armageddon.
So, I think it'll be fine. And then
we'll have the uh 7.5 Army Academy will
be in August. Okay, I'll talk to you
guys a little later. Peace out. See you
next week. Next week will be story. See
you there.
>> See you.